all right it is that time where we have
to talk about Joe Biden when we first
saw that one or two percent of the vote
come in from the Iowa caucuses on Monday
night it didn't look good for Joe Biden
now we have as of this recording 71
percent of the vote counted and it still
doesn't look good for Joe Biden now with
71 percent reporting Joe Biden based on
the current numbers would get 0 pledged
delegates from Iowa 241 state delegate
equivalents which puts him in fourth
place now remember that Joe Biden was
polling in second place going into Iowa
these results are panicking the
Democratic establishment because their
goal is for an establishment friendly
centrist candidate to be the nominee
those candidates were in order of
perceived viability before we got the
Iowa caucus results the order of
perceived by ability for the centrist
candidates was Joe Biden number one Pete
Budaj Edge number two and Amy Klobuchar
number three Biden with 71 percent of
the vote counted in Iowa looks like he
is losing badly to mayor Pete and is
barely ahead of Amy Klobuchar and
meanwhile the Democratic establishment
now has limited time to decide do they
want to switch horse in the Democratic
primary and it's not just mayor Pete and
Amy book club a chart that they are
looking at remember that Michael
Bloomberg has huge cash reserves there
are even questions about does it make
sense for the demo stablishment to start
pushing Bloomberg in order once again to
deny Bernie Sanders or at this point it
seems less likely Elizabeth Warren the
Democratic nomination there are concerns
in the DNC about how does Joe Biden
justify raising money given his results
in Iowa his fundraising has been okay
it's not been great but if he does end
up four in fourth place in Iowa where he
currently stands why would establishment
centrist Democrats whose priority is for
Bernie not to be the nominee
why do you donate to Biden instead of
mayor Pete Budaj edge does Michael
Bloomberg increasingly seem
like the way to go for the establishment
because he has nearly unlimited money
remember Bloomberg has more than fifty
five billion dollars in net worth he's
spent it's over a hundred million I
don't know if it's approached or
surpassed two hundred million dollars at
this point
Biden's campaign reportedly has nine
million dollars on hand I mean two crazy
amount of money but it's almost nothing
compared to what Michael Bloomberg has
already spent nevermind what he would be
capable of spending without even
remotely affecting his financial
situation so there are some donors who
supported Hillary Clinton in 2016 one
example is Alex Sink who said people she
knows are waiting to see how Biden does
in a couple more primaries before
deciding about giving Biden more money
fourth place in Iowa is not going to
inspire a lot of financial contributions
to the Joe Biden campaign and Biden
aides previously said you know he
doesn't have to win Iowa or New
Hampshire because he's likely to do well
in Nevada and South Carolina maybe
Bernie Sanders of course doing very well
in New Hampshire Nevada is now close
Biden was barely up in the last poll
South Carolina still Joe Biden's
strongest of the first four but one
recent poll says Biden's only up five in
South Carolina and these polls as we
know are not always completely accurate
so go back to the selling point for Joe
Biden the selling point for Joe Biden to
the extent that there is or was one is
that he's experienced and he's electable
Joe Biden is not exciting I hear very
few people even Biden supporters say
that Joe Biden is exciting Joe Biden's
not bringing in a large cohort of new
voters who are planning to vote for the
first time and they want to do it for
Joe Biden that's not happening Joe Biden
is certainly not progressive and is not
in line with what is increasingly at the
point of view of Americans on more and
more issues be it health care or many
others it's the sort of legacy sales
pitch the legacy statesman of Joe Biden
but if he can't win primaries he was
barely viable in Iowa the case for Biden
as the safe reliable legacy statesman
from the Obama administration evaporates
very very quickly
so my question to you where do you
believe the establishment will move if
they move from Biden will they go to
Buda edge if indeed Buda edge sneaks out
the Iowa caucuses although again it
would be roughly the same level of
Delegates as Bernie Sanders would it go
to Amy Klobuchar who almost tied Joe
Biden in Iowa based on the results we
have right now will the Democratic
establishment say we should go to
Bloomberg he has the money for the long
haul he is focusing remember Bloomberg
got zero in Iowa but he also didn't even
campaign there he's skipping right to
the Super Tuesday states where do you
believe that the establishment will go
if indeed Joe Biden's viability remains
a question mark to put it lightly let me
know do you feel like you just don't
have enough time to become as
intellectually well-rounded as you would
like to be that there are just not
enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about 8 bucks a month
but you can try it for free for a week
and get 25% off a subscription when you
go to blink accom slash Pakman what
blinka studs is take thousands of
popular non-fiction books and condense
them into either text or audio that you
can read or listen to in just 15 minutes
and what you get is all of the most
important ideas and information from the
book imagine being able to listen to an
entire nonfiction book in the amount of
time it takes you to drive or walk home
from work I just finished listening to
the way we eat now by bee Wilson whose
work I've recommended to you before
super interesting look at how the global
food system works and impacts the way
that we live blink is has totally
transformed how I consume information I
love it of course I read a book in its
entirety when I can but there are simply
just so many books that I want to read
and would not have the time for if it
weren't for blankets they have books on
politics economics philosophy science
you name it you can try it out yourself
totally free for a week and get 25% off
if you decide to subscribe just
by going to blink is comm slash Pakman
I've put the link right underneath this
video like the rest of us I bet you're
going into 2020 thinking about what you
didn't get around to in 2019 and your
goals for the new year if you want to
work towards being your best self in
2020 understand more about the world
around you and make sure that your time
is well spent then blink astiz for you